la diabetes tipo 1 es una afección en la
cual el páncreas no produce insulina una
hormona que el cuerpo necesita para
mantener los niveles apropiados de
azúcar en la sangre
después de que usted come alimentos que
contienen carbohidratos
los productos químicos en el intestino
delgado
los descomponen en moléculas de azúcar
simple llamadas glucosa luego las
células que recubren el intestino
delgado absorben la glucosa
la cual pasa al torrente sanguíneo
cuando la sangre llega al páncreas las
células beta del páncreas detectan el
incremento de los niveles de glucosa
las células beta liberan insulina en el
torrente sanguíneo para reducir los
niveles de glucosa y para mantener la
glucosa sanguínea en un nivel saludable
la mayoría de las células del cuerpo
tienen ciertos receptores en su
superficie que se unen a la insulina
circulante
la insulina actúa como la llave de una
cerradura para abrir la célula de tal
manera que la glucosa circulante puede
ingresar a dicha célula
ahora las células pueden aprovechar la
glucosa y producir la energía que
necesitan para funcionar correctamente
si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 1 las
células beta del páncreas pierden su
capacidad de producir insulina dando
como resultado altos niveles de glucosa
en la sangre y otras complicaciones
en la diabetes tipo 1 el sistema
inmunológico específicamente los
glóbulos blancos consideran a las
células beta pancreáticas como si fueran
cuerpos extraños
en una respuesta autoinmune los glóbulos
blancos segregan anticuerpos que
destruyen a sus propias células beta
como resultado el páncreas produce poca
o ninguna insulina
sin la insulina la glucosa no puede
ingresar a las células dichas células
están desnutridas debido a la falta de
las calorías que deberían recibir de la
glucosa
además el nivel de glucosa se acumula en
el torrente sanguíneo dando lugar a una
afección llamada hiperglucemia
los síntomas más comunes de la
hiperglucemia en la diabetes tipo 1 son
apetito y sed excesivos necesidad de
orinar frecuentemente pérdida de peso
inexplicable
cansancio debilidad irritabilidad y
visión borrosa
si la hiperglucemia no se trata usted
puede enfermar gravemente debido a que
usted no tiene suficiente insulina en la
sangre las células no pueden utilizar la
glucosa para obtener energía
como resultado el cuerpo descompone las
reservas de grasa y de proteínas como
fuente alternativa de energía
a medida que la descomposición de la
grasa continúa ciertos subproductos
conocidos como cuerpos cetónicos se
acumulan en la sangre dando lugar a una
afección llamada cetosis cuando los
cuerpos cetónicos se acumulan a niveles
peligrosamente altos se produce una
afección llamada cetoacidosis diabética
que puede poner en peligro la vida si
los niveles de glucosa en sangre siguen
siendo altos a lo largo del tiempo se
pueden producir problemas de salud a
largo plazo tales como aterosclerosis
ceguera daño a los nervios y enfermedad
renal
si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 1 su
meta es mantener la glucosa en sangre
dentro de los niveles normales esto se
logra a través de una combinación
adecuada de reemplazo de la insulina
control de la glucosa en sangre y de
igual importancia al seguir una dieta
saludable y realizar ejercicios de forma
regular
debido a que el páncreas deja de
producir insulina usted deberá
administrarse insulina para reemplazar
la que su cuerpo debería producir
un profesional médico autorizado puede
capacitar lo para que usted mismo se
inyecte la insulina de manera subcutánea
deberá administrarse varias inyecciones
al día
y alternar los puntos de aplicación de
la inyección para evitar daños en los
tejidos y problemas de absorción
otro método de aplicación es mediante
una bomba de insulina la cual va
adherida al cuerpo y le administra la
insulina a través de un tubo implantado
bajo la piel
usted tendrá que revisar el nivel de
glucosa en la sangre varias veces al día
con un glucómetro
para esto debe pincharse el dedo con una
aguja pequeña llamada lanceta
y colocar una gota de sangre en el
glucómetro
conocer su nivel de glucosa en sangre le
permite ajustar la dosis de insulina las
calorías que consume durante las comidas
y la actividad física que realice
usted deberá seguir una dieta saludable
y realizar ejercicios de forma regular
para controlar el nivel de glucosa y
reducir el riesgo de sufrir enfermedades
cardiovasculares